la chronique de l'environnement comme
tous les mardis vous en avez l'habitude
nous sommes toujours en direct si vous
venez de nous rejoindre aux alentours de
18h30 et j'accueille donc sur ce plateau
julie rocha suarez pour formuler bonsoir
donc nous recevons ce soir rosine
rowland qui est présidente de
l'association harper chevreuse
pourquoi militez-vous pour une
réglementation des antennes relais et
des ondes électromagnétiques en général
sur tout ce qui concerne la téléphonie
sans fil
le wifi le wimax le dec téva toutes ces
choses là qui sont dangereuses pour la
santé et qui se déploie d'une manière
totalement anarchique et sans aucune
sans aucune responsabilité par rapport à
la santé des gens donc on essaye de non
pas de d'éliminer le téléphone du tout
mais de faire en sorte que ce soit
compatible avec la santé publique tout
simplement dans votre quartier dur aux
dons à chevreuse une antenne avait été
placée dans le jardin d'un particulier
en l'an 2000 vos jumelles ont vu leur
état de santé se dégrader à partir du
début des émissions de cette antenne en
2003 on avait fait un sujet à l'époque
cette époque on va le regarder ensemble
les hauteurs de chevreuse un quartier
résidentiel avec ses pavillons sa forêt
et son antenne relais elle domine
lotissement depuis maintenant cinq ans
et depuis cinq ans juliette et caroline
roux landes souffrirait selon leur maman
de troubles du sommeil de nausées ou
encore de troubles cardiaques
encore une fois ce ne sont pas que mes
enfants 1 c'est pratiquement une maison
sur deux d'un quartier où les gens se
plaignent au minimum de troubles de
sommeil sas est pratiquement tout le
monde de vertiges de motets de problèmes
de thyroïde même les chiens du quartier
et c'est pas anecdotique quand je dis ça
parce que c'est pape sy cosmétiques chez
un animal et c'est franchement un bon
témoin l'animal on voit par exemple
quand les truites ne font pas bien dans
hier on sait que la rivière est polluée
donc des chiens qui ont des problèmes de
thyroïde quand il ya quatre cinq chiens
d'un quartier qui ont des premiers de
thyroïde en plaisir mais il se passe
quelque chose hein ce quartier les
parents ont donc déposé plainte au pénal
une première en france pour
administration de substance nuisible de
certificats médicaux précise que les
maladies dont souffrent les jeunes
filles sont susceptibles d'être en
rapport avec l'antenne téléphonique
proche de leur domicile
joint par téléphone la société bouygues
telecom a répondu qu'elle ne commentait
pas une procédure en cours ah mais la
loi les autorise et alors comme ils
disent on est on est tout à fait dans la
loi puisque on n'aimait pas on aimait en
dessous de la norme et la norme
française est tellement aberrantes ne
pourront jamais et m
même au niveau de la norme ils peuvent
aller jusqu'à 61 volts par mètre j'ai
pas s'ils l'ont fait c'est comme si on
disait pas le droit de dépasser trois
mille kilomètres à l'heure sur
l'autoroute
évidemment ils dépasseront jamais cette
norme il ya beaucoup de pays en europe
qui sont à 3 4 ou 6 volts on demande la
même chose
en mars 2008 la famille roulant
d'équiper ses fenêtres de rideau
spéciaux contenant des fibres d'argent
ses rideaux limite la pénétration des
ombres dans la maison
résultat certains troubles des jeunes
filles notamment les troubles du sommeil
se sont atténuées je rappelle donc ce
sujet avaient été tournées à votre
domicile roselyne bellande en 2008
comment se portent vos jumelles
aujourd'hui va elle vaut mieux parce que
ça fait un an et demi qu'elle ont quitté
la maison qu'elle étudie à bruxelles et
vous seul êtes une ville intelligente où
les missions des rôles est limitée à 3
volts par mètre en plus elles sont à peu
près à 500 mètres de l'antenne la plus
proche donc elles vont mieux et elle
d'en mieux même leur coeur serré radical
et non radicale radicalement tout cas
c'est significatif
disons qu'on a fait effectivement elles
sont alors retournés voir un cardiologue
ya six mois pour voir où j'en étais et
de 120 à 130 elles sont passées à 90
battements par minute pour suivre quand
même un sacré gain par rapport à ce
qu'elles avaient elles dorment mieux son
manager donc oui c'est un cetain tout
bénéfice pour elle
vous avez engagé votre combat il ya de
nombreuses années on a vu le reportage
et quelques instants qui étaient
réalisés en 2008 est ce que les choses
ont changé du côté de la loi aussi est
ce que vous avez réussi à obtenir
modifications avec votre combat au
niveau de la loi n'ont pas vraiment et
d'ailleurs on voit qu'il y avait une
proposition de loi qui aurait dû être
débattu fin janvier l'assemblée
nationale et qui a été directement mis
aux oubliettes sans même qu'ils ne
dépassent donc c'est une c'est très rare
je crois que c'est même la première fois
que ça se passe donc nos niveaux de
lanouaille laloyer encore rien
aujourd'hui on est que les opérateurs
sont on va dire protéger à oui quelle
que ce texte est tout à fait quand on
voit mais un pèlerin qui disent qu'il
était qui déjeunait avec les opérateurs
la veille justement de du jour où la loi
devait passer voilà qui disait vous
inquiétez pas je vais bien me battre
pour les 8es contre ces peurs
irrationnelles c'est pas très rassurant
pour ses incroyables de parler en 2013
de plug de peurs irrationnelles
quand on sait que l'om chat quand même
classé les ondes électromagnétiques dans
la même catégorie que l'amiante est que
le plomb et que le bisphénol a qui
connaîtra est interdit dans les biberons
qui va bientôt l'être partout on se dit
c'est incroyable d'oser parler de peur
irrationnelle on est quand même on va
écouter un autre primonial oui voilà vos
jumelles n'ont pas été les seuls dans le
quartier être touchés par certains
symptômes
on a rencontré par stéphane loriot
pardon il hier qui est atteinte
d'électro sensibilité depuis la mise en
place de cette antenne dans le quartier
de chevreuse
on va regarder son portrait tout de
suite
antennes relais téléphone sans fil et
portables micro-ondes bornes wifi ou
encore ampoules basse consommation sont
devenus un calvaire pour stéphane loriot
souffrant d'électro sensibilité depuis
dans sa va selon elle relaie dans mon
quartier il ya plus de dix ans les
premiers insomnies ce mettait déjà en
place les migraines constante
puis après tout la panoplie avec le wifi
qui se rajoutent rapidement par la suite
le wifi ça va provoquer le sait demander
au tout départ après une sensation de
l'enfoncement de la cage thoracique une
douleur au coeur de l'eczéma qui
appareil qui repart sur sur mon visage
ces symptômes se transforme en véritable
handicap à gérer dans son activité
professionnelle
quand vous avez des trous de mémoire
quand votre machine de travail c'est la
mémoire et la parole et que vous devenez
bègue
je peux vous garantir qu'avant chaque
prestation toutes ces petites choses qui
sont sur cette table là sont
incontournables obligatoire le tanakan
les baies de goji est et la sauge c'est
la base
lortie puissant évidemment mais c'est 3
ces trois ingrédients je me dois de les
prendre pour ne pas bégayer pour avoir
un esprit éclairé enfin bref savoir ne
pas s'incliner vers le mur tout de suite
officiellement diagnostiqué intolérants
aux ondes en 2011
il a fait aménager son bureau au château
de la madeleine à chevreuse pour être à
l'abri des sources électromagnétiques
son espace de travail est tapissé de
rideau en fibres d'argent une matière
qui diminue l'intensité des ondes grâce
à ce certificat effectivement j'ai pu
obtenir par ma hiérarchie l'autorisation
pose est celle de mon fils d'argent qui
coûte tout de même la bagatelle de 600
euros payés grâce à vos impôts s'il vous
plaît j'insistais pour ce soit le cas
pour qu'on puisse dans le milieu du
travail déjà fait relancer un peu le
dossier stéphane loriot assure ne pas
être un cas isolé et prête volontiers
son pollue au maître qui capte les
champs électromagnétiques ambiant juge
mais pour une prise de conscience
collective des risques selon lui il
reste du chemin à parcourir
il continue donc de militer au sein de
l'association harpe à chevreuse donc
l'antenne a été retiré depuis peu de
temps aux adjoints de l'année dernier
la suite à des actions que l'association
art pas à mener entre autres c'est aussi
parce qu'on arrivait à la fin du bail
mais disons que c'est suite à nos
actions que les propriétaires ont
accepté de résilier le bac
le bayern en avant et que maintenant et
bien étonnamment dans le quartier les
gens dorment mieux ça s'est fait assez
rapidement au bout de trois mois les
gens disaient mais c'est formidable je
retrouve le sommeil j'ai pu ses
palpitations parce que c'était quand
même tout le quartier qui n'allait pas
bien elle restait combien d'années cette
antenne à chaud elle était elle a été
mise en 2000 mais n'a commencé à émettre
en 2003 ce qu'on avait fait déjà
beaucoup d'actions à l'époque pour
retarder et on n'a fait que retarder
malheureusement donc elle a cramé mais
me voilà presque dix ans quoi et votre
plainte au pénal pour administration de
substance nuisible avait été déposée en
la procédure est encore en cours tout à
fait on en est où
c'est en cours d'instruction donc le
voeu expertise ses voilà donc on en
attend c'est d'accord et quelles sont
vos attentes
quels sont vos espoirs et bien que le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
qui tiennent compte des résultats qui
sont observés sur la commune de choses
mais qui soit observé sur toutes les
communes de france
on est juste une commune parmi les
autres de france et d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs un et au vu de ces résultats
qui sont quand même catastrophique on a
joué les cobayes pendant toutes ces
années mais en principe il ya une
expérimentation regarde ap comment se
portent les cobayes 606 portman on en
tire des conclusions donc là ça serait
bien qu'ils tirent des conclusions
qu'ils arrêtent de je dirais deux
copines et que les opérateurs c'est il
n'y a pas que les intérêts financiers
dans une histoire comme ça il faudrait
qu'ils tiennent compte de l' alerte de
l'om est quand même de toutes ces
centaines les des centaines d'études
scientifiques indépendants évidemment
qui prouve qu'il ya des gros gros
problème n'est pas simplement le
syndrome du micro-ondes dont on a tous
plus ou moins souffert d'un quartier il
ya tous les problèmes dhs comme stéphane
qui n'était pas du tout une vachette
faisons électrohypersensibles au départ
qu'il est devenu au fur et à mesure des
années et pour l'instant il ya 3 % à peu
près de hs dans le monde ça va être en
augmentant on va pas attendre elle qui
menait 10 ou 20%
il serait bien de tenir compte de ses
conclusions qui montre aussi qu'il ya
une recrudescence de de l'autisme c'est
assez grave tout de même de la maladie
d'alzheimer chez les gens jeunes des
problèmes évidemment de cancers en
particulier il ya une explosion des
gliomes des cancers cérébraux
il serait bien qu'ils ne tiennent compte
de tout ça qu'ils appliquent simplement
la résolution par exemple du conseil de
l'europe qui date d'il ya deux ans et
qui parle de ce vin du principe de
précaution
donc on voudrait que enfin on passe au
0,6 volt par mètre qui ce qui est tout à
fait faisable il suffit de mettre des
antennes plus nombreuses un peu
différente donc ça va péter un peu
d'argent opérateurs il faudrait
supprimer le wifi qui est totalement
inutile et dont on peut pas se protéger
et il faudrait mettre des fils tout
simplement c'est moins pratique c'est
moins joli mais c'est pas dangereux
on vous préconisez la technologie
filaire câble tout à fait tout à fait et
puis faire un moratoire total sur la 4g
qui une fois de plus ses films
technologie qui va être mise en place
sans qu'il ait eu aucune expérimentation
avant on imagine va pas que les
médicaments sony comme ça sur le marché
on va piquer des scandales malgré les
précautions qui sont prises mais là la
4g la 3g la de gfa tout a été mis en
place comme ça on savait que c'était
dangereux la 2g parce que c'est une
bande de fréquences qui a été vendue par
l'armée s'il est trop de problèmes de
santé cathy vendu cher aux opérateurs
par le gouvernement on savait que
c'était dangereux ça nous a été imposée
à tous
après on a eu la 3g maintenant on va
voir la 4g et tout ça sans aucune étude
préalable c'est absolument incroyable
les portables je le rappelle sont la
principale source dont deux
électromagnétiques aujourd'hui est la
recette qui est l'autorité de régulation
des communications électroniques et des
postes indiqué au 31 mars 2012
69 millions de clients des services
mobiles
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire est-ce
que l' indice das ds et du débit
d'absorption spécifique devrait être
réduit suivant les modèles de téléphones
plus il va mieux c'est il faudrait aussi
que les gens sachent comme un téléphone
mobile c'est pas parce que c'est devenu
courant que c'est banal comme
utilisation normalement c'est pas plus
de trois minutes de conversation et deux
heures de pause entre chaque
conversation pour que le cerveau puisse
récupérer et sur plus de 3 minutes 30
minutes de prestation d'affilée c'est
justement vos furets ont une utilisation
très raisonnable pour toi là on a été
relié dans le rad acheté 400 arrivé en
belgique parce qu'il a fallu trois mois
avant qu'elle est téléphone filaire dans
leur appartement et elle n'avait pas non
plus internet donc c'était impossible de
les joindre et pour leurs profs et pour
nous donc elles ont des téléphones gsm
qui ne font que téléphone est qui et qui
en gros coupé toute la journée
elle regarde leurs sms ou leurs messages
deux fois par jour elle ne communique
que par sms et elles se servent du
filaire quand elles arrivent chez elle
et tout le monde le moi même je pas
téléphone portable et je m'en porte très
bien et je veux dire que l'on peut très
bien vivre sans ça tant qu'on n'a pas
mis la main dedans mais le plus
difficile sera de faire changer aussi
les mentalités filaire le wifi par
exemple oui est-ce qu'on va vous
répondre ça il faut revenir au minitel
et monte en gamme bientôt donc
oui mais dans les mentalités ça va être
difficile c'est vrai simplement le wifi
offert la même technologie avec les
filets pas millions de dollars sur la
technologie le téléphone portable
on peut s'en servir mais quand on est à
côté du téléphone filaire c'est
peut-être pas la peine de ce qu'on a
l'impression que les gens ont conscience
ou même sur le wifi si on réalise un
micro trottoir je suis sûr que les gens
donc gérer et on sait que le wifi c'est
dangereux mais après tout mais ça se
voit pas même le téléphone ne voit pas
donc temps que ça se voie pas simplement
que je maîtrisais sur le long terme
sur les séquences des gens qui vont
venir vhs comme stéphane mbia
malheureusement on s'est passé peut être
vous ça peut être moi même dans un angle
de mes filles sont pas réellement
richesse mais elles ont quand même
souffert mais dans le quartier c'est
incroyable le nombre de personnes qui
ont souffert il ya quand même eu
beaucoup de décès dans la même rue à
moins de 100 mètres de l'antenne trois
personnes courrier cancer de personnes
qui au fil crise cardiaque à moins de
100 mètres de l'antenne et dans un laps
de temps qui nous fait penser que
c'était quand même il ya s'appuie la
dass n'a jamais voulu faire les antennes
des enquêtes sanitaires qu'on demande et
donc on sera toujours dans le dos depuis
il ya eu énormément de problème donc dû
au manque c'est dangereux pour la santé
pourquoi pas privilégier le fil si c'est
que ça c'est donc votre combat qui va se
poursuivre oui il imagine bien merci à
vous joli on poursuit la chronique de
l'environnement après les
électrosensibles la jambe après tout à
fait donc trois dates à retenir pour
cette semaine la formation les plaisirs
du jardin proposé à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux
ce samedi 23 mars à 10h prodiguera les
connaissances de base sur les
différentes cultures possible graines
plants smith ou tunnel cette session
débute tout un cycle de formation sur
les méthodes de jardin
âge animé par l'association ville verte
deuxième date samedi également une
randonnée thématique construire passif
c'est positif
une balle à deux des huit ans dans
différents quartiers de magny les
hameaux pour découvrir des exemples de
réalisations écologiques comme les
maisons à ossature bois
les terrasses végétalisées départ à 14
heures de la maison de l'environnement
de magny les hameaux
troisième rendez vous encore samedi un
café repaire sur la question comment
favoriser l'apiculture et la production
agricole
animé par jean pierre moreau
entomologiste et ancien directeur de
recherche à l'inra
ça se déroule dès 17 heures au bistrot
de marly à marly le roi
merci je lis mardi prochain pour cette
prochaine chronique de l'environnement
le 7 8 qui se poursuivit lui et pour
terminer je vais recevoir les
représentants du rotaract club
le mot d'ordre des jeunes adhérents de
ce club l'amitié par le service pour
l'instant en loisir avec du modélisme
apprendre à construire un avion en
modèle réduit le thème d'un atelier
proposé à saint cyr l'école encadrés par
une association les clés du ciel enfin
prêt à décoller le cirad haut à saint
cyr l'école a proposé aux adolescents
pour la première fois une activité de
construction de planeur les moniteurs du
club d'aéromodélisme des
clayes-sous-bois ont appris aux enfants
à construire leur propre avion
ils sont partis de planches de balsa les
deux baguettes lesur selon leur a donné
des gabarits qui leur ont permis de
dessiner de couper les pièces ensuite
sur notion d'indication les ont les ont
collé avec les on les en tenir avec des
épingles et quand cet étau nuit là le
contrat était collé il a fallu lester
ces petits avions et maintenant ils sont
prêts à voler
légèrement c-32 sert à donner une
meilleure ambiance que d'habitude et en
plus c'est bien ça occupe
parce que j'ai apprécié donc déjà s'il
construit mon premier avion puis serait
déjà c'est donc c'est mon tout premier
est aussi basse avoir fait découvrir
quelque chose que je connaissais pas
pour clôturer le stage les enfants ont
été invités au thon à d'aéromodélisme
entre les meilleurs pilotes de la
discipline clayes-sous-bois